-My next guest is a great actor,
a 16-time WWE world champion
and a best-selling author.
You can also see him
in a Super Bowl commercial
for Mountain Dew Major Melon.
Here is John Cena!
[ Laughs ]
Wow!
-Hello, Jimmy Fallon!
-Wow, John!
This is unbelievable.
I knew that you were
going to do something.
-This is my job.
-This is your --
Wait, I love it.
This is Peacemaker?
-This is the first actual
interview that Peacemaker
has ever done, and I wanted to
bestow it upon you,
and it's
a really special occasion.
So thanks for having me, man.
I love being there in person,
but because we're miles away,
I wanted to --
I wanted Peacemaker to show up.
-Wait, I love this. Wait.
I have so many questions
because this is --
We talked last time
you were here.
You were our first guest
in studio, by the way.
Thank you for doing that.
And you said you're doing a
spin-off series for Peacemaker,
and here you are as --
Are you on set?
-Yeah, so this is
actually Peacemaker's house,
and on the contrary, Peacemaker
was like a polar opposite
of Bruce Wayne,
where Bruce Wayne
would be a billionaire
with a bat cave.
I live in a single-wide
and this is my outfit.
So it's a bit of an interesting
story and a bit of a new tale.
-How do you describe
this character?
-I would say like a douchey,
bro-y Captain America.
-[ Laughs ]
I love it. Can you show --
Do you have pants?
Do you have a cape?
What do you have?
-Oh, dude, if you want it
to get weird,
I'll show you the full piece.
Is this what you want?
-[ Laughs ]
No, no, I don't want to
get weird.
This is unbelievable.
I love that you did this.
That comes out in August, right,
"The Suicide Squad"?
-Yes, in August, and then
"Peacemaker" will be out
shortly after that on HBO Max.
-I heard this rumor about you
in the movie --
and let me know if it's true --
that one of the most difficult
scenes in the movie
involved you eating an empanada.
We have a photo of some --
-Oh, man.
The stunts were incredible
and filming the movie
was treacherous,
but that right there
is the face of defeat.
That is me eating
my 37th of 40 empanadas.
We had to do this one big take
because the horribly beautiful,
corrupted mind of
James Gunn operates
in so many intricate pieces,
and he wanted this big, giant
take where I thought
it'd be cool to like,
"Oh, it'd be funny
to eat the whole empanada.
Throw the thing over my
shoulder, the guy catches it.
It's gonna be great.
Everybody's gonna
think it's awesome."
I had to do it 40 times
and nearly ate myself sick,
and you can tell by that picture
I was not having a good day.
That was my most difficult stunt
in "The Suicide Squad."
-Could we see that photo
one more time?
It's just such a good photo.
It has to just --
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God. Is that number 38?
-If that doesn't turn out
to be some sort of meme,
then the meme culture is dead!
-[ Laughs ]
Exactly, right?
John, I read that last year
was the first year
that you weren't able to
compete in WWE Raw
since 2004,
but you will be back, right?
-Yeah, I will.
I just, unfortunately, you know,
the state of the world, I mean,
I'm not sitting there
on the couch next to you.
It's a difficult
and unpredictable time,
and right now I'm doing this.
I'm filming "Peacemaker,"
and that's going to take a lot
of my time and I can't
bounce back and forth
due to
international restrictions.
So at least for the time being,
I'm here,
and I'm still away from WWE,
but I very much
look forward to returning
as soon as I possibly can.
-You really are one of
the hardest working guys I know.
In the middle of everything
you're doing,
you're also in a Super Bowl
commercial this year.
I want to talk about
this commercial
because it's for the new
Mountain Dew Major Melon,
and this is your second --
this is your second --
-Yeah, man, let's talk about it.
-This is your second
Super Bowl commercial.
And it's just interesting to me.
-I know,
back-to-back Super Bowls.
I mean, this is incredible,
second Super Bowl commercial.
This is great.
-I mean, I hate to cut you off
and everything like that,
but last year I asked you to be
in a Super Bowl commercial
with me and this year,
you're in a commercial.
I just find it interesting
that, uh...
[ Laughs ] That you didn't
ask me to be in it.
-Oh, yeah! No, no, no.
So, long story short,
Mountain Dew Major Melon
came to me and said,
"You know what?
We want to do this awesome
Super Bowl commercial
that's gonna reinvent
advertising and the way
people watch the big game.
Who do you want
your sidekick to be?"
I said, "Of course, I want it
to be Jimmy Fallon."
They said, "We can do that
or we can give away,
on behalf of
Mountain Dew Major Melon,
a million dollars
and change somebody's life."
So I thought to myself,
"What would Jimmy Fallon do?
Jimmy Fallon
is a man of the people.
Jimmy Fallon would want to
change someone's life."
Jimmy, don't you want to
give someone
the chance to win
a million dollars?
-Yes!
-Yeah, so screw you being in
the Super Bowl commercial.
You're the man that's gonna
be the vehicle to give somebody
a million dollars if they can
identify all the bottles of
Mountain Dew Major Melon
in the big game's commercial.
-Now, okay.
I feel a little bit better
about this.
So basically what you're saying
is if you watch the commercial
during the Super Bowl
and you have to count how many
Major Melon bottles
are in the commercial?
If you can count them and --
-This one's a layup.
Everyone's already gonna be
watching the Super Bowl.
Watch the Mountain Dew
Major Melon commercial
because you're gonna be watching
all of the commercials,
count the number of
Mountain Dew Major Melon bottles
that you see, post it, and tag
Mountain Dew's Twitter handle.
And if you're right,
you can win a million dollars,
and that's, in a long way,
thanks to you, Jimmy Fallon.
-Wow.
-Thanks to you.
-I just want to say I'm honored
and I can't wait to see
what I do.
-You're gonna change
somebody's life.
-Yeah.
-You're gonna change
somebody's life.
-See?
-Jimmy Fallon giving away
a million bucks.
-I love you and I love that
you're doing this.
Do you want to play a game
when we come back?
-I would love to!
-Here we go.
-I don't know how you're gonna
slap me with a fish,
me being 3,000 miles away,
but, yes, I'll play a game
with you.
-More with John Cena
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.